je suis déçu comme tout le monde de la
lenteur de la vaccination
je suis déçu aussi que pour une partie
de la population n'est pas organiser
quelque chose qui permet de l'accès à la
vaccination je pense aux plus de 75 ans
qui ne sont pas en milieu urbain pour
lesquelles la prise de rendez vous par
dr l'ibu d'autres outils et quelque
chose de complexe et qui à mon avis
aurait pu être réfléchir un peu avant
le point important enfin moi je voudrais
insister sur le fait qu'il faut pas
s'illusionner sur les capacités que l'on
a à mener de façon théorique telle ou
telle politique
on le voit sur le vaccin les moyens que
l'on a de se projeter rapidement et
correctement sur les populations qui ont
besoin d'être vaccinés ne fonctionne pas
lorsqu'on a démarré la vaccination trop
rapidement ça a amené à annuler des
rendez-vous de vaccination et ça s'est
relativement perturbant et la fragilité
extrême que l'on a notre système de
santé y compris notre système de santé
publique et de loin ce qui nous pose le
plus de problèmes donc quand on se
compare à d'autres pays qui n'ont pas
les mêmes structures qui n'ont pas les
mêmes moyens et qui n'ont pas les mêmes
organisations
c'est pas une question d'acceptation des
français ou de refus des français c'est
simplement un principe de réalité qui
est que nous attaquons l'épidémie deux
pas du tout dans des bonnes conditions
en termes de système de santé et y
compris en termes de santé publique
[Musique]